benvenuti solita scorre oggi nuovissimo
e ski promo visto che la scorsa del
macellaio che vissuta tanti no questo no
ma che in queste nuove che dovremmo fare
da la paninoteca vogliono trasformarci
dei burger è mangiarci super divertente
ma invece comincerò maggior di tutti i
panini per evitare che provo solo le sue
preferite perché c'è il cibo poi
ovviamente mettete un mi piace qui sotto
se non mi seguite ancora su instagram
adatta a seguire una umanità stars
mettetevi comodi presumo kors è lì siamo
subito ecco qua c'è scritto che papas
borgheria cioè la panineria di papà
vediamo cosa dice il fuoco fa il nostro
chef signor burger è impazzito sta tanto
da mangiare alla gente hamburger romani
lascia scappare abbiamo retto meglio che
noi capiamo burger romani
che c'è della mostarda che è colato
dappertutto eccolo è lì come ho detto
che si chiama mister hamburgers mista
pubblico ecco lo guardo al mese per
burger e la testa di un umano diciamo
proprio un boccone no grazie
ho salvato vedevo che cosa c'è qui
c'è una festa nella cucina ha preso
fuoco da mettendo le teste degli altri
degli altri per giocatori nella nella
piastra poveri signore darli in qualche
modo penso che ormai sia troppo tardi e
c'è anche un osso qui insieme a due
hamburger o no beh speriamo almeno che è
successo se si esclude un altro perché
non mi mangia m a per fortuna non mia
vita apriamo almeno di riuscire a
sconfiggere queste riguarda i possente o
no ha fatto avere dobbiamo riuscire a
liberarli dai colli ghiaccia qui aspetta
perché questo tizio ha scheletri nel
congelatore
buongiorno a torella sto io per te che
tener congelatore perché aveva guardato
sofia ostro sul lato ei cuoco vieni a
prendere invitare pronto per farina
ha pure tu no quindi tu ti sei sposata
due volte dio solo un rivederci qui
commenti quante volte il destro
accennato vitale quanti utilizzano
stress e la thai e degli scheletri là
sotto non ci credo vitale mia superata
devo arrivare prima io ma cosa ci fanno
egon i gelati a questo paninoteca non ha
spesso a se non avete visto le strip
room nel canale di evitare in cui
capiamo dal gelatai lesotho legge la tua
musa andrea andate a vederlo poi dopo
questo video supporta sei dove sei
aspettami ha combattuto io pensavo fosse
già avanti ma qui c'è qualcosa tipo le
patatine la graham e proprio ristorante
gigante e si con la carne umana però che
ci sono deputati del gruppo
no non è sovrastato fritto che ma
chiedono uno tutto daccapo amenta ma io
resto è
tifo riusciresti a poco perché così
difficile devo prendere la misura meglio
sì prendiamo la rincorsa
tumefatto ok il trucchetto per superare
queste pratiche è guardare dall'alto
ecco come lo ha detto grato vitale
albero no
questa mattina sono difficilissime l'ho
fatta ecco il cuoco lì sembra un po
spaventato vediamo evitare quando si
sfracella
votiamo no
perché valuti sporcelli dipartono prima
catena ecco il burger di carne umana
aiuto giganti c'è anche una friggitrice
gigante mentre l'olio di fuori
all'attenzione se l'olio per terrà
infatti meglio non pagarci sopra viene
bruciato
presunta modernità via grotta di dove
sei e sono ancora lì bloccato in mezzo
alle patatine anche dal continuo esploso
l'ardimento se devo andare no c'è
scritto che sto può entrare solo lo
staff personale che mister ha preso
fuoco a fuoco ha preso fuoco
ma nel presente le piccole ma da che
parte dovrà usare adesso qua ci sono i
gelati
non posso andare da che devo stare sulle
tue come stanno stata presa stefano le
patatine anche raggiunta
giusto il tempo
di mattina seconda tappa di qua sulle
patatine
dentro toccare un olio bollente però
è solo una di quelle
sì adesso stai rubando la strada però
visto dimenticata presto a raggiungerlo
il signor burki avrà dimenticato di
spegnere le macchine pregio lato gelato
guardate come cento però penso che sia
meglio sono venuto
sono scivolato surgelato e congelato la
sotto difficile poi ti raggiungo no
lasciato mi piace di incoraggiamento per
evitare sarai mica qui promozione ma ciò
non mi piace per tutto apprendiamo
ci sei quasi c'ero quasi ma o no di
nuovo le patatine fritte
[Musica]
paladina piano piano
sono dietro le ordina mengaroni
devi guardare dall'alto vitale si fa
distrarre troppo dal cbs che fianco ci
sono anche quei panini
vediamo cosa ci aspetta
sembra che anche il signor burger abbia
lasciato il rubinetto della fota andiamo
in giro ma ha lasciato aperto
vita vedi un po distratto dimentica
tutto aperto
c'è un problema eccolo lì è pronto a
farci avvertire il pomodoro è qui che il
cibo viene cucinato per
questo viene cucinato in là va là va
nella griglia forse la rete trenini
sbrighiamoci aspetta perché questo si
aggirano
si poteva velocemente quello che si giri
no
io che dico io l'ho capito ok non so
come sia cresciuta la retta io invece
non sono presa lato kukai stimati già so
fare allora bisogna scegliere lavora all
agatine fritte ok non è quella viva tipo
supera in italia
sono già avanti tu e maliziosi ciao
tanto verrei affettato la mostarda
però c'è una cosa veloce fuoco cannibale
come hey hey aspetta no lei andando nel
numero e allora dice la nostra unica
fuga attraverso lo scarico del lavandino
ma come lo sbloccheremo forse vedi qui
c'è il lavandino forse bisogna saltare
su questa molla qua un tremito solofra
che se i coltelli casali sa li
vedi qua sopra sopra
allora attenta perché credo che bisogna
saltare sui coltello ok
no mi sono mai stato accettato
ormai mi affido al marito che come ti
aspetta ok
basta questo aspetto mi rovino
dovremmo passare dalle tubature del
lavandino per scappare albi duomo
colomba eccoci ma diventerà mai un bel
io vedo tutto va tutto piano ancora
perché non hai un primo tempo è stata
allora devi tornare a passare coltelli
per aver portato ma gli sprechi sui
coltelli ok evitare che l'ha fatta
propose buttando via
ma anche qui c'è qualcuno non c'è da
meravigliarsi che il cibo è sempre
bruciato lo cucina nella nata
abbiamo beccato lo vedi
ma quindi dobbiamo dare
forti basi
ovviamente il pavimento della va quindi
non toccare niente non
c'è mancato poco quanto tempo ci metterà
abitare a sfracellarsi ma c'è chi non ha
la riguarda che sono
comune è che sentito il rumore di
frittura di evitare insomma c'è una
scala affrontare qua oppure
come no non ci credo pensavo di poter
salire in uno di questo nome la propria
metà campo perché vuol dire che io sono
in vantaggio non devo sbrigarmi
eccomi
sono né una stanza piena di formaggio ne
devi andare veloce
venire una trappola non bisognava
passare di là di modica
riuscito a passare ciao
forse ho capito la mia perfetta e poi
qua
ok ce l'ho fatta vediamo
wow questo corridoio sembra strano
saliamo bello giusto 8 siamo ancora
dentro al ristorante il pavimento e lava
di nuovo quindi ci metto do un
equilibrio
bene queste scale no non se la musica si
possa spingere non possiamo ridare
non mi aspettavo che queste scriptum
fosse po difficile quella del macellaio
era abbastanza facile
questa è divertito di arrivare il sileno
come fatto a saltare la
ducati si arrampica
veramente
hai fatto
cardinale che cos'è questo è un pulsante
per agente lo spegnere si schiaccia però
avendo viola mandare c'è un burger
umano che penso che voglia risucchiava
orbo come risucchiarci guardate ma anche
un ordine sa adesso a mese scritto rene
no noi un punto
beh almeno non so mangiato in un fuoco
cannibale carino con quelle orecchiette
fatto a forma di oliva
allora o no
o no cheeseburger del signor burger ciò
appena mangiato questo caso sembra
familiare
vincenzo sembra familiare infatti non
capisco che siamo dentro a uno anche di
averne umana
fish e cosa o guarda e anche nella porta
ha fatto di burger r
e un'altra estetico
quindi non si doveva salire sulla
salsiccia è un'altra equipe room dentro
le skifo
ma bisogna andare forse bisogna saltare
sulla salsiccia no non capisco quando si
può andare fermo a saltare in
continuazione
altra non avete idea di quante volte mi
sono sopra gelata adesso dobbiamo
saltare attraverso la sera per qui a
natale è diventato così o mi ha detto mi
sono spogliata lato allora devo dirlo
più no perché brume difficilissimo ma
roba lo aspettiamo ok ho trovato il modo
stiamo guardando
l'ultimo
sì ce l'ho fatta ok abbiamo
scritto insieme all'uomo via penso che
dobbiamo andare velocemente
davvero bisogno a
parte fritto devo tenere l'equilibrio
demo in altissimo importante che ha
superato vitale
si faccia e
ora la mia cosa preferito materia
bisogna saltare sulle patatine fritte
sull'olio qui ecco vitale che sta
raggiungendo devo sbrigarmi io ho fatto
un tuffo nell'olio spesa per istigare
anche prudente speriamo che siano seta
ecco vitale
cosa è successo siamo ancora dentro al
ristorante loco a cesano delle scorie
radioattive rotto perché non mi è super
ci sono un burger che cadono nella
stanza accanto il trucco sarà quello di
evitarli
ok
ma
se tipo la spazzatura eletto papa
ha appreso
che bello vedere evitare spiaccicato
tutto bunker rotolata sono stato
investito da un burger crediamo sia la
scena
io rimarrò che ha tutto il tempo per
vedere vitale che viene inseguita dai
furti
vediamo vediamo un video lei
vedeva arriverà ad esser burger si va
avanti
questa cattiva ad ora
riproviamo
bugiarda
vidal e rimarrà fermo qua tutto il tempo
non ce lo sai prova io aspetto sincero
la posta quando vedo che si avvicinano
entro dentro perfetto che adesso il
momento di stilare arenate nel momento
giusto forse se lo fa forse ce la fa
burger siamo quasi fuori siamo quasi
riusciti a scappare benissimo fuori
dalle strade ai lavori che celava anche
qua nel parcheggio si è dimenticato il
rubinetto della lav abert 26 allagato
anche il parcheggio è ben
chiara prima
dietro
non sono cose normali
siamo scappati dalla borghesia del
signor burger ora riesce a trovare il
distintivo perché non abbiamo preso non
ho appena preso e che cosa segreto da
questo
questo bella come si prende e
proprio faccia premio come il fatto che
dobbiamo prendere un oggetto per
romperlo allora io sto provando con il
salto forse nascosto che con questo
posso volare io sto soltanto vediamo qua
dall'alto se tra un anno non lo trovo
qui ma sono trovato guardate queste
tutte allestì prum che abbiamo appena
fatto vista dall'alto
ritrovate forse l'ho trovata una cosa
così dopo vediamo
e qui c'è un cappello un cappelletto
volante
e pron completato il belgio non li
troviamo va invece nascosti comunque
super divertente mi raccomando la barbie
piacere e ora vinciamo 4 casi su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite milione
ciao